besoin? On a demandé à de ce qui
suit le plus ce dossier-là
depuis des années, Jean Thomas
Bernard, économiste. Bonsoir.
Première question : est-ce qu'on
qu'on doit lancer une
construction? Ça ne serait pas
prêt avant 15 ans.
- Ce qui semble le plus ferm
c'est le 3000 MW d'éolien. De
l'éolien, c'est de l'énergie
alors qu'Hydro-Québec est plutôt
en manque de capacité. Ça ne
semble pas très utile pour le
moment. Un barrage, ça produit
de l'électricité et de la
changé qchangé qchangé qchangé s
urgent de construire un barrage
alors qualors qualors qualors qs
rapports d'Hydro-Québec, on ne
comme Madame Brochu l'a indiqué.
Ce qui a changé dans les
derniers mois, le secteur de
l'énergie toujours en mouvement.
C'est l'explosion du prix du gaz
naturel. Ça peut rendre
l'hydroélectricité attrayante
sur le marché américain en
particulier, mais il y a ausquii
voudraient se relooker ici,
relocaliser ici paès.
- Ça ctionnairectionnairectionne
seul et principal dise à Hydro-
Québec : accélérer le pas, je
table d'ici quelques mois pour
une production d'ici une dizaint
pas urgence, puis les sauts dans
le marché de l'énergie, on n'en
a vu. Lorsqu'on a lancé le
projet la Romaine il n'y a pas
si longtemps, c'était cet
argument. On voudrait s'occu
des changements climatiques, le
nord-est des États-Unis n'
voisins qui pourront leur en
fournir. Pendant toute cette
période à venir jusqu'au dernier
mois, le prix de l le
prix du gaz naturel était très
faible. ort
d'Hydro-Québec, on a déjà eu des
faramineuxfaramineuxfaramineuxfe
prix a augmenté aux États-Unis.
- Dont vous dîtes oui à ma, le t
favorable pour qu'on regarde çax
barrages.
- Qu'on regarde ça sérieusement,
oui.
- L'autre question : où? Quels
sont les rivières qui ont
nombre de rivière
- Les deà
considérimmédiat,
petit mais Catilina, déjà
mentionné dans les plans de
Island, au Labrador. Il y avaitr
Boutcha et Monsieur Tobin. En
termes de possibilités dedéveloe
serait ces deux rivières.
- Deux rivières qui prennent
Mécatina qui descend la haute
Côte-Nord ou Gull Island.
- C'est un projet plus gros
alors que Petit-Mécatina est
assez se
veloppement.
Hydro avait dépensé 500 millions
ire les études'a pas passé.
- Confère barrages, il y a un
Est-ce que vous voyez des défis
environnementaux gigantesques er
avec les peuples autochtones?
- Pour ce qui est de Petit-proc.
Il faudra s'entendre avec les
je n'anticipe pas de difficultés
majeures. Ce n'est pas une
rivière qui a été
particulièrement pour ses autres
attraits comme les aspects
touristiques. C'es
très éloigné. Ça n'a pas été
particulièrement soulevé de ce
côté-là. Il y a d'autre rivière
autour du lac Saint-Jean qui
pourrait être développé.
- Vous dîtes que c'est plus
petit que grandes baleines, mais
cet ouvrage la qui serait la
Est-ce qntntntntntntntntntntntnt
pour changer la donne?
Est-ce qui est resté de nouveaux
courants disponibles?
- On parle de 2500.
C'est la taille de La Romaine.é.
- C'est important?
- C'est pas ça qui va changer la
face. Ça pourrait satisfa
justement, certains besoins de
capacité sont urgents pour
l'Hydro. Quoiqu'il
façons aussi de considérer ce
problème. Mais disons que c'est
à cela s'ajoute la flexibilité à
Hydro-Québec.
- Il n'est pas dit qu'il ne
deux deux deux deux deux deux x
ouvrages. Bon.
- Mais pas en même temps. Non.
- C'est une bouchée à la fois!
Jean Thomas Bernard, ce sera